Ukraine has finally chosen their entry for Eurovision
and it's now widening their lead to win the competition.
First off, there were 11 competitors in the final
and the winners won by almost seven times more votes
than the entry that came in second place.
So it's safe to say that Ukraine
is definitely feeling this.
Basically, the song
shines light on the strength and resilience of woman
and uses Mother Teresa and Virgin
Mary as symbols of perseverance.
Overall, it's an emotional piece
and it is very pretty, although
I'm not as hyped as most other people seem to be
because it doesn't stir up any intense emotions.
On top of that,
the melodic hook of the chorus,
the part that goes na,
na, na, na, na,
na, na, no, no,
no, that part repeats itself four times in each course,
making it a little bit repetitive and monotonous
for me. Overall,
I still like it.
I maybe just not as sold as most other people seem.